the author of a highly critical new book
about the Trump administration says
people better wake up to what's going on
inside the White House Bob Woodward
spoke first to David Martin for CBS
Sunday morning about his book fear Trump
in the White House it's published by
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS David
is here with more of Woodward's claims
and the pushback by the administration
David good morning thanks Bob Woodward
is used to being denounced by the White
House going all the way back to
President Richard Nixon and Watergate
his reporting is almost always proven
accurate and he is confident it will
stand up on the criticism this time from
President Trump how many people did you
interview Oh
over a hundred I you know I would say
that maybe half of those are key people
the theme of Woodward's book that aides
fear what the president might do if
allowed to follow his impulses received
an unusual confirmation last week when
the New York Times published this
anonymous article written by a person
described as a senior official in the
Trump administration I worked for the
president but like-minded colleagues and
I have vowed to thwart parts of his
agenda and his worst inclinations I have
no idea who it is
it's very important who it is it's very
important whether this is somebody who
witnessed and participated I'm quite
frankly if there was a person in the
White House or the administration who
wanted to tell me what's in that op-ed
piece I would say okay name me who was
there what is the specific incident as
you know from having read my book there
dates and times and participants I
wouldn't have used it - very well too
vague and not does not meet the
standards of trying to describe specific
incidents specific incidents are the
building blocks of journalism as you
well know fear Trump in the White House
is Woodward
19th book and he says reporting it took
him deeper inside a working White House
than he's ever been before this one was
in the belly of the beast
and what did you conclude about the
beast that people better wake up to
what's going on according to Woodward
people who work for the president were
so worried of what he might do that they
stole documents off his desk so he
couldn't sign them Woodward said you
look at the operation of this White
House and you have to say let's hope to
god we don't have a crisis David let me
ask you about one of those specific
incidents that writes about he says
there was a tweet president President
Trump was ready to send that he did not
send but that might have led to a
conflict in North Korea what was that
the tweet that the president drafted
according to Woodward was to pull the
family members of all the American
troops in South Korea out of the country
which is a step you would normally only
take when you were about to begin
military action the tweet was not sent
because of a back-channel message from
the North Koreans that they would regard
a pullout of dependence as a sign that
an attack was imminent and Woodward says
there was this profound sense of alarm
at the Pentagon at the belief that they
were one tweet away from convincing the
North Koreans that the u.s. was about to
attack is chilling chilling to hear that
detail tweets do matter thank you David
thanks David